>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Thank you
everyone for joining us.
I'm Carla Hayden, Librarian
of Congress and I'm here
in our beautiful main reading room
for a very special announcement.
Tonight I'm going to share with
you the names of the authors
who will appear on the
main stage of the Library
of Congress National Book Festival
on September 2nd and I am announcing
that for the first time, all
of the main stage author
presentations will be accessible
to you on Facebook Live.
[applause]
>> CARLA HAYDEN: And of course
joining me is Ron Charles,
Book Editor of the Washington Post
and now the National Book
Festival is made possible
by generous supporters
and the Washington Post has been
a charter sponsor and a supporter
of the festival since its
very first year in 2001.
>> RON CHARLES: It's been
a pleasure to be here.
Now, the festival has been the
highlight of my year every year.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Oh good
because you know the authors.
>> RON CHARLES: I do.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: And you
know them intimately.
And I thought that it would be fun
to talk with you about the line
up as we announce it and to get some
of your thoughts about the authors.
>> RON CHARLES: It's
great to be here.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: So before
we get started though,
I just want to mention that we're
so grateful for the sponsors
of this event who make
it possible each year.
And first, I'd just like to
thank our National Book Festival
co-chairman, Mr. David Rubenstein,
without whom the festival
would not be possible.
And I'd also like to thank
our charter sponsors,
the Institute of Museum
and Library Services
and the Library's James
Madison Council
and the Washington
Post and Wells Fargo.
And our patron sponsor, the
National Endowment for the Arts
and many other contributors
and friends.
So, without further ado, here we go.
The first author who will be on
the main stage and live streamed
from the festival is one of
our most revered historians,
David McCullough.
[applause]
>> CARLA HAYDEN: The winner
of two Pulitzer prizes
and the Presidential Medal of
Freedom and his latest book is,
The American Spirit: Who We
Are and What We Stand For.
And Ron I know you have
thoughts on Mr. McCullough.
>> RON CHARLES: It's just great
to have David McCullough here
because he is one of our
country's greatest historians
and certainly one of our most
beloved historians in book
after book like Truman
and John Adams.
He's been able to present the
past in a way that's accessible
and illuminating and gives us
all a sense of where we are.
It's one thing to be able
to do research in a way
that David McCullough does,
but it's another thing to do it
in such a fundamental and ancient
way as to tell a captivating story.
You know, to involve
people in that history.
And as you know, he's a
great champion of libraries.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Yes.
>> RON CHARLES: And in
this particular library,
I heard him speak here
a few years ago.
He delivered one of the most
impassioned and moving defenses
of why we need to support
our libraries.
It was a personal testimony to
what the library means to him
and his research and for anyone who
wants to learn about our country.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: He's one of my
favorites as you can imagine.
He has used the Library of Congress'
resources for many many years
and he is a great supporter.
And now the next author.
Now this is the wildly
popular Diana Gabaldon.
Did I say it correctly?
>> RON CHARLES: Very close.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Ok, you correct me.
>> RON CHARLES: Diana Gabaldon.
I'm so excited she's coming back.
I met her at this festival
about ten years ago.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: And her
newest book is Seven Stones
to Stand or Fall stories.
>> RON CHARLES: Yes, now when I met
her ten years ago she was popular,
very, very popular.
But now she is so much
more wildly popular
because of her Outlanders series and
the TV show based on that series.
She's a fantastic speaker.
She's very funny and she has this
fascinating backstory too, you know.
She has a PhD in ecology.
Yeah and she's a computer scientist
and she just decided on a whim once
that she would see what it was
like to write a historical novel.
She was inspired by Dr. Who
and so she just sat down
and started doing research and then
from that came all of the novels
and the beloved characters that we
know from the Outlanders series.
This story about a
woman who goes back
to 18th century Scotland
and falls in love.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Oh wow.
>> RON CHARLES: Since meeting
her in Washington here years ago,
she started to review for
the Washington Post a couple
of times a year and she
is always a delight.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Well,
I'm going to practice
and make sure I pronounce
her name correctly.
>> RON CHARLES: She won't mind.
She'd love to meet you.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Well, the third
author in our exciting line
up is J. D. Vance who has written
a powerful account of growing
up in a poor rust belt town and
it's entitled: Hillbilly Elegy.
>> RON CHARLES: Everybody I know in
Washington and across the country,
is talking about this memoir.
As you say, it's a
remarkable story about growing
up in a poor rust belt
town in a broken family,
pretty dramatically broken family.
But, J. D. Vance managed to
graduate from high school,
to join the Marines and
then go to Yale law school
and then become a venture
capitalist.
And last year he published this
memoir about his life that gives us
such an insight into a huge segment
of the white underclass that most
of us don't have access to.
And in addition to being
a really stunning story,
it offers a unique insight into the
political revolution that we saw
in last year's presidential
election.
And it raises some difficult
questions about what we can do
or even how we should
help these people who are
such a major part of America.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: I've heard so many
people talk about this book in terms
of policy and what's
been going on lately.
So, this book is really
on the best-seller list
and also in lots of discussions.
>> RON CHARLES: And you know
after each author speaks,
people can ask questions.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Yes.
>> RON CHARLES: And that's going
to be the most provocative
parts of this presentation.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: I can't wait
because the next notable appearing
on the main stage is
the best-selling,
The World is Flat author,
Tom Friedman
and his latest book is Thank You
for Being Late: An Optimist's Guide
for Thriving in the
Age of Accelerations.
And I think we all are feeling that.
[applause]
>> RON CHARLES: Tom Friedman,
the New York Times columnist
has been explaining the world
to all of us for years.
He's won three Pulitzer prizes
and in books like The Lexus
and the Olive Tree and as
you said, The World is Flat,
he's shown himself to
be an illuminating guide
to our rapidly changing world and
his new book takes on that subject
that is change and
acceleration as its very subject,
Thank You for Being Late.
It's what he calls an
Optimist's Guide for Thriving
in the Age of Acceleration.
When everything seems so
chaotic and we're all writing off
in so many directions at
once, Friedman has a way
of showing us how things
are connected.
And in this book, he shows us
how technology, globalization,
and climate change are all
accelerating from basic forces
that he explains and shows
how those forces will continue
to change our community
and our politics.
It sounds really wide
ranging and it is.
But, rather than feeling
overwhelmed, what Friedman does
so well is help you get a sense
of how you can live a more
thoughtful life amid all
of this change.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: I'm hoping
to find some answers in there
and to talk with him about it.
And then, I'm really
thrilled to announce the name
of our next main stage author,
former Secretary of State,
Condoleezza Rice who has written.
[applause]
>> CARLA HAYDEN: a
comprehensive history
of America's struggle toward
democracy in her book, Democracy:
The Long Road to Freedom.
And I think that thoughtful
approach to this road that we're all
on together is going
to be something.
>> RON CHARLES: Getting guests
like Condoleezza Rice is what the
National Book Festival is all about.
Here is a woman who has
established so many firsts
for women and African Americans.
She is a remarkable person.
She was Secretary of State, she
was National Security Advisor.
She's been in the middle of some
of the most fundamental
geo-political changes
of our lifetime, certainly.
And she's a professor.
Time Magazine named her as one
of the world's most hundred
influential people four times.
And her new book, oh she
also holds the record
for having traveled the most number
of miles as Secretary of State.
And her new book, Democracy: Stories
from the Long Road to Freedom,
she lays out in clear and convincing
ways why promoting democracy is
still so crucial for the United
States and that is an argument
that has become pretty
essential to our country
after the new presidential election.
So, that is a debate she's
right in the middle of,
we're all talking a lot about.
And I think it's pretty fantastic
that we're going to have her here,
hear from her book, and
then ask her questions.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: That's the
thing about the Book Festival
and this opportunity to
interact with authors
that you might not get a chance to
see any other time and to be part.
And our final author on the National
Book Festival's main stage is a
perennial on the New York Times
best-seller list and someone
that it's very interesting that
we'll get a chance to meet him
and see him and that's
David Baldacci.
>> RON CHARLES: He is amazing.
He's written as you know...
[applause]
>> RON CHARLES: more
than thirty best sellers,
more than a hundred
million copies in print.
And did you know that he
once imagined and wrote
about a murder here at the library?
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Oh no.
>> RON CHARLES: Yes.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: I think that
things happened around here.
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah, he killed
off the head of Rare Books
and Special Collections
in one of his books.
Anyhow, David goes
back here a long ways.
He was born and raised in Virginia.
As a teenager, he delivered
newspapers,
which are things people used to
find in the yards every morning.
After law school, he practiced
law here in Washington,
DC and then about twenty years
ago, he wrote his first novel.
He sold it, everything changed.
Clint Eastwood made a movie about
it and sense then as you said,
he's been on the best-seller
list pretty much all the time.
He's got this ingenious imagination,
so much so that certain members
of our government have
interviewed him
about how terrorists might attack
the United States so they can plan
and thwart those attacks.
But, here's a really
wonderful thing about him,
he and his wife Michelle
are changing people's lives
in the most profound way.
They have a charity called
The Wish You Well foundation
that encourages family and adult
literacy all across the country
and because hunger is
so tied to illiteracy,
their organization also works
to cure hunger in America too.
He is a really, really great
guy, a real hero of mine.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Right and
to be able to make that tie
and let people know about the
tie between hunger and illiteracy
and the need to solve both at
the same time is significant.
>> RON CHARLES: It is.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: This is going to be
an exciting year, especially for all
of the fans of the authors
who are watching tonight
because what's wonderful is
that no matter where you are,
you too can join us at the
National Book Festival September 2nd
on Facebook Live and you
can go to loc.gov/bookfest
to get more information about the
incredible list of authors appearing
at this year's festival which
will include Michael Lewis,
Alice McDermott, Kate DiCamillo,
Kwame Alexander, and NASA astronaut
and former wide receiver for the
Detroit Lions, Leland Melvin.
So this will be quite a year and
Ron we can't thank you enough
for giving us a sneak preview.
>> RON CHARLES: I was
happy to do it.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Because
it's going to be something.
So see you soon and we hope that
you will all join us Facebook Live
and also in person.
>> RON CHARLES: That's true.
It's all free here in town.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: It's all
free so thank you all.
We appreciate it.
>> RON CHARLES: Bye bye.
[applause] [background talk]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.